vote no on the recall ladies and
gentlemen our governor
california governor gavin newsom is at
risk of being voted out of office on
tuesday in a rare special election
so how did a democratic politician who
sailed to victory in a blue state end up
becoming only the second governor in
california history to face a recall
newsome's handling of the covid19
pandemic in california has become the
most prominent issue in the race we have
autonomy over our own body to give
ourselves what we feel is the proper
medical treatment for our condition
and if we don't want the vaccine we
shouldn't have to take it i think he's
done a good job with kovid response i'd
like to see him continue his term
depending on who you're asking gavin
newsom either crippled the economy and
closed schools and left kids to suffer
in virtual learning or he took the tough
but necessary measures to keep
california safe and so that's kind of
really a test in this election who are
you going to believe recall efforts are
not uncommon in california in fact every
governor since 1960 has faced a petition
for removal and for newsom this is one
of six attempts by republican activists
since he was elected in 2018 but it's
been very rare for those recall attempts
to actually reach the ballot in order
for a recall to be triggered the
petition has to be signed by enough
verified signatures to equal 12 of the
votes cast in the last gubernatorial
election in the state's only other
gubernatorial recall republican arnold
schwarzenegger replaced democrat gray
davis as governor in 2003 so what has
contributed to this latest recall effort
the original petition was written
shortly before the pandemic hit and
cites common complaints that
conservatives have about california high
taxes layers of regulation and policies
favorable to immigrants
but newsom's troubles grew as the
pandemic took hold and many californians
became frustrated by restrictions and
mandates including policies that closed
businesses schools and houses of worship
then last november the recall effort
gained steam on the 13th as coven 19
cases across the state began to rise
state officials asked residents to avoid
gathering with people outside their
households four days later news photos
surfaced showing the governor dining
mask-less with lobbyist friends at the
french laundry an exclusive napa valley
restaurant by chance earlier that day a
sacramento county judge gave recall
petitioners an extra four months to
gather signatures citing closures due to
the pandemic it really encapsulated the
anger that people had over what they
felt was his hypocrisy and his privilege
this idea of rules for thee and not for
me was just this
overarching theme that really drove a
lot of people's anger and caused them to
sign this petition newsome has said that
dinner was an error in judgment within
weeks the total number of signatures on
the petition to recall newsome grew from
about 56 000 to nearly 500 000. by april
the petition had collected more than 1.7
million signatures to qualify for the
ballot before the recall officially
qualified the campaign's strategy was
really avoidance and really not talking
about the recall this spring as kova 19
cases started to level out newsom
projected optimism california has the
lowest case rate
in the united states of america which is
significant when you consider the size
and scale of our state the density in
this state he really tried to telegraph
that the state was on the mend and good
times were coming
that kind of all changed when larry
elder joined the race this summer there
are several big issues the the biggest
one is the rise of homelessness the rise
in crime the outrageous cost of living a
conservative radio host from los angeles
elder quickly became the top polling
republican ahead of 45 other candidates
on the ballot his platform includes
increasing home construction to reduce
the state's high prices school vouchers
and tougher anti-crime policies elder
has also criticized newsome's covid19
restrictions and has pledged to end
vaccine and mask mandates right now this
governor has required every state worker
who's not been vaccinated to be tested
once a week and to wear a face mask at
work when i become governor one of the
first things i'm going to do is to
repeal that mandate
even though polls project newsome
winning the race has turned out to be
much closer than experts initially
expected prompting some of the most
prominent people in the democratic party
to campaign for him protect california
by voting no
on the republican recall
the special election is local to
californians but some experts argue the
outcome of the vote has broader
significance
there's plenty of people who are
disgruntled about newsome's coveted
shutdowns about his mass mandates about
his vaccine mandates and this is really
a test as to whether
people approve of those policies or not
in terms of the national context you
know this is really significant in terms
of um a peak into 2022 in terms of
engaging voters
in terms of you know whether or not
coveted response is a winning message
for democrats
you